we are back and I'm here in Justin give
it up
everybody one of my favorite things
about Justin and seeing him laugh is
that he loves a horn section I do as
well instruments like the Sachs trumpet
and trombone definitely breathe a
special energy into music our next guest
is a very talented Trumpeter who came I
don't say Trumpeter enough it's a weird
word um who came to a stark realization
when he was growing up he didn't know
any female trumpeters uh now he's
working to change all of that with his
New Orleans based nonprofit girls play
Trumpets too please welcome Troy
everybody me
Justin so you said growing up you didn't
see any females playing trumpet right
right so my first instrument was a
violin I played that for a couple of
years and then I picked up the trumpet
in fourth grade so growing up in New
Orleans you know it's a Brass City drum
City but I didn't see it's a musical
City the bird place of jazz and so I
didn't see any professional female
trumpet players growing up so I felt
like girls and women could not play the
trumpet on a professional level
absolutely when whenever I I heard you
say that earlier I was like I don't know
that I did either like now that I'm
thinking about it even like I love a
horn section on stage and I don't know
that I I noticed I you have brass always
involved in every show you do yes the
energy just gets lifted with with brass
sexier it's yeah yeah yeah I like a
trumpet um well you you have a theory
though of why few women play right well
yes because the trumpet is a lead
instrument and represents leadership and
so for a long time especially band
directors would discourage girls from
playing that lead instrument cuz they
felt like they were not leaders they
were not strong enough so they'll put
them on a woman instrument like a flute
you go play that flute you're not strong
enough to play that trumpet yeah and so
growing up in New Orleans like I said I
didn't see any professional female
trumpet players until I saw one that
came she came from Canada to New Orleans
and performed at Diller University and
she was playing a lot of mil Davis's
Tunes yeah mil Davis is one of my
favorite trumpet players besides
Armstrong you know and so I was like wow
she can play so it had Knocked Down the
Walls of gender bias within me and then
traveling around the world seeing
professional female trumpet players that
I be actually became their best friend
like okay yeah yeah it's inspiring so
who would you say like your I think my
favorite female musician would probably
be Sheil I just love working with her
and I love her so much and I love
percussion because I can't keep time
like that um but who is one of your
favorite female musicians oh gosh
there's so many um Nina Simone Oh yeah
that's my favorite Simone me that's is
yeah I mean Eda yeah and because for me
you know I think sometimes you know
somebody like Whitney or Eda was like oh
they're your favorite singers but they
were musicians right you know to the
full extent and um I mean there's so I
could keep going on and on but we only
have so much show as
well everybody knows they a singer but
great pianis exactly how did you start
girls play trumpets too like how did
where did that kind of start so you know
the devastation of um how Hurricane
Katrina devastated New Orleans and um
you know traveling around the
world and being away from home and
seeing all my my fellow just new orans
being um devastated by that storm and I
got away you know I evacuated so I felt
like it was my responsibility to come
back and go back to New Orleans to help
build New Orleans yeah and then I got
inspired to join this organization that
will get professional musicians that
have degrees to teach at a school that
didn't have enough money in their budget
to pay for a full-time music teacher and
that organization is called artist
school New Orleans so it got me into
actually teaching music in the school
system and I'm the only black male
teacher there so I felt like they were
looking at me and I felt like they
needed me and I needed them I said you
know what I'm going to keep it going and
I decided to put a after school program
together yeah specifically focusing on
the trumpet teaching everyone how to
play the trumpet but my best best
trumpet player was a girl yeah and she
said do you know who valeta snow is I
said no I don't she like you don't know
who Val snow is what's wrong with you
and so so disappointed in you oh she was
she was so Val snow was a black woman
that played the trumpet that traveled
all over the world in 1920s yeah and so
she's our inspirational model for girls
play Trumpets too I was scared at first
I'm like I don't know if I can do this
program but my lady encouraged me to do
it she said that's it yeah and she's I
was like trying to come up with
different names yeah for the program she
like no girls play Trumpets too t o o
that's it keep it simple yeah yes very
memorable got good ideas every time I
trumpet I win every time I trumpet I win
there you
go nice call
[Music]
back what's up everybody I'm back with j
t like and Troy Troy is the founder of
girls play Trumpets 2 in New Orleans and
you just saw a couple of his students
showing off their skills so Choice
nonprofit offers girls more than music
lessons it's also creating a Sisterhood
which is very important joining us now
are two of his students 9-year-old
Bailey and 11-year-old Chana give it
up welcome to the show ladies meet
Justin I know you know
Troy so I have to ask so you were
amongst the first to join right so what
was it like what was the first
experience well when I joined girls play
trumpet 2 I was very nervous because I
couldn't even play not one note like
yeah you got started somewhere I
couldn't even hold the trumpet yeah but
now I can actually play all the notes
okay nicely done what about you Bailey
uh it was okay because you know like it
it was like really inspiring cuz you
know like you get a little nervous
sometimes but at the same time you know
like K say we cannot play a note at
all those are when the parents are like
just keep going in the house I played
violin when I was a kid and well there's
a reason why I still don't um yeah it's
was not good but what do you think
you've learned about yourselves because
it's also about connecting like when I
was in choir as a kid I loved also like
the friendships that I made in the class
so it's about that as well right I
learned that trumpet actually brings out
a a lot of joy in me yeah it's a joy
that's so beautiful and simple I love
that what about you
B uh it's it's the same thing like your
s say it also brings out the frequency
you know like all the music in like one
whole bunch you it really brings out so
much joy in everybody you know what you
just said I love that you like the
feeling of it cuz I remember I sat in on
a session in a studio and it was like a
string section horns there's a whole
Orchestra was there and sitting in the
room you feel like the vibration the
wind from the it's like it's a magical
thing to feel I'm glad you brought that
up um and to be in tune with that at
such a young age is so cool what do you
what do you see in these girls like what
are these qualities in these girls so
one thing about Chana I have been
teaching her for a couple of years and
she will always bring this joy and I
called her Smiley she's always smiling
see you look at her right now I called
her Smiley then when she join girls play
Trumpets too she said oh my stage name
is Coco call me Coco so welcome to the
stage
Coco you got a stage name I like
it the one thing I could say about
Bailey she's a deep thinker her
responses are deep and she will come
early to girls play Trumpets too before
all the girls come because she was like
I hope they don't come so I can get a
private lessons so that says a lot about
her and I call her the Serena Williams
work ethic yeah you got to put that
extra time in and you know she really
wants to get some extra time better I
love that it takes dedication to get
good at something so that that's awesome
do you have any advice for the girls I
feel like um I feel like I want advice
from
them I remember being so young and being
so inspired by music and and knowing
that it affected me in such a positive
way so just to hear how you're so tapped
into like it really it really is a
different frequency you know and also to
the
relationships that you will make and
your life with other musicians that
share this same feeling will be
relationships that you will never forget
they will become your extended family
like I talked about the musicians that
tour with me and the musicians that I
get to play with in the studio and so
many friendships that are made over this
feeling that you share about creating
music together and I I don't I don't
even know what to say I'm so blown over
blessing to be a part of these two young
old souls over here yeah um so where do
you see the pr program going from here
so we want to expand we actually
expanding to schools for um creating
Partnerships with schools to do after
school programming yeah and so we're
actually in need of more trumpets uh
more music stands more um method books
and and funds to actually pay the
instructors to teach at these different
schools and especially because they're
taking music and art programs out of
school so like after school programs are
so important right so important and um I
want to expand it to the world to where
we can actually do it online and so yeah
and reach everybody reach everyone
because girls and women could play
trumpet too yeah yeah you came
well there is a surprise that Justin has
so I'll let you take over from here I'm
in my hometown in Memphis I'm ve very
hugely involved with sta Academy which
is a music program for um you know young
people in in Memphis and and um I
remember being
um I think it was probably third or
fourth grade and the music program in
our school got cut and it was
heartbreaking for me but I heard about
y'all story and um I was just really so
touched by the whole thing that I wanted
to make a donation to make sure every
student gets a new trumpet yeah which
those are
people
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home